welcome back to Ghana I'm joshing
tonneaus and I'm Alessia Cara and we are
gonna get agony on on your problems
today yes we are are you ready yes I am
steady go so you were in London yes
we're here to promote the new album yes
we are if we were gonna do a QVC style
pitch to sell your album how would you
pitch it this album is about growth and
the human experience
oh do so if you're a human you should
listen to it I think I was pretty good
though speaking of human experiences we
have got some agony art style questions
here that we want you to answer okay
some of them are from Twitter from your
fans some of my own deep foul issues
that I need to get your help with cat
what advice would you give someone who
was scared of growing up which is handy
because the theme the album is about
growing up yeah that's really good um
well that's tough because I too am
afraid of growing up but I would say
it's important and I know this sounds
very cliche but it's important to be
present and live in the moment because
that I think along Gaetz your life and
your youth if you are present stay young
by just doing things that make you happy
not trying to grow up so fast and not
worrying so much about not having things
figured out because a lot of the time
people that are grown up don't have it
figured out either so because it's 16
you think you're gonna be like a
billionaire like living with like have a
husband like six kids just Lee when you
get to 28th that is the half a day yeah
yeah this is from Sophie she also has a
growing pain in her handle so she's a
big fan big fan how do you remind
yourself that you are worth it just do
little things to take care of yourself
because if you're telling yourself that
you're worth it then that's all that
matters who cares what other people say
you should you should tell yourself that
you're worth it because you are doing a
lot of things that make you happy
whether it's like moisturizing your skin
in the morning you know just like
looking at myself in the mirror some
days and just like trying to mentally
tell myself that I'm beautiful and that
I'm good enough and that I'm gonna enjoy
my day I've always told myself in the
mirror I'm like got there exactly about
yourself little nook little post-it
notes I'm gonna stop doing that I like
just those tiny little things make a lot
of difference I need to up my karaoke
game how am I getting this okay yeah
what performance tips could you share
your karaoke like a lot of hand yes this
on the mic yeah yeah like that that
really helps what let's do that and then
come straight also on the singing it's
like strong fingers no what is the best
piece of life advice you've ever been
given
yeah that's Tesla that's the log 22
years of advice and what would you say
to someone that doubts their ever
achieve their goals this is from Lily
yes
I've started yes I've started to know
all over my name just names yeah I knew
it was Lily I would say Lily my parents
always told me take things one day at a
time because I tend to worry a lot about
the future so that's always been really
good it's like focus on what you're
doing today that's been really helpful
and also happiness comes from within you
and people can only affect your mood and
your circumstance can only affect you as
much as you let it you can't change
circumstance all the time but you can
change your perspective yeah I like how
wise you are thank you I know it's not
from so this is a bit of a love life
advice I need to win back someone I
ghost and how do I suddenly Dom be them
Dom what's a zombie-like that's when you
like reappear you could send them the
text like I'm just kidding
I would say if you ghosted them for no
reason or if you were a little bit
I thought maybe go back and apologize
and say yes listen maybe I wasn't ready
I goes to do because whatever reason and
then you say but I but I would like to
redeem myself and I would like to come
back because you shouldn't you shouldn't
just come back cuz that messes with
people maybe they got over you and now
that you're back and yeah icing up their
their day so you gotta like you just
apologize and you you make amends with
the past yes now this is not relate one
to that what's the best way to get
someone's attention he fancy yes I have
been half licking a tree but it's not
working
am I being too subtle oh maybe yeah
maybe you should go up to them and be
like I've been I've been here for
looking and you're not you're not doing
anything you stopped me that foreheads
or just keep hair flicking or like wink
you're talking to someone who talks to
nobody so I wouldn't if I see someone
that's attractive I'm just like and go
the other way you're like do you have
any advice for a young girl trying to
make it in as a music artist and this is
from Joe Joe Joe Joe oh yes of course
he's trying to make is she's the best
well Joe Joe I would say well you're
already talented so you have that
checked off you write your own songs
which is amazing sometimes it can be
hard as a young girl to assert yourself
or to prove yourself and you're gonna
have to prove yourself a lot in this
industry but I think as long as you
maintain a really strong part and a
strong vision for what you want to do
not what everybody else wants you to do
and you work really hard for it and you
remember that saying no is okay it just
as it is to say yes you'll be good be
good
I love how you know the bowl I sweet and
I talk to them all the time they've been
around since like the beginning why do
you think you've been so successful so
young G thang
well I think obviously you have to work
hard and you have to have a passion for
what you do and connect with people but
I also think it takes
just like fate and luck and being in the
right place at the right time honestly
because there are a lot of people that
are probably way better than me that's
just like but I just happen to someone
just happen to see a video of mine and
you know it takes like things to a line
I know that I'm really lucky because
there are a lot of really cool people
out there hey babe I think you'll kill
out oh this is a cute one
this is from Josephine yeah hi Josephine
what advice would you have for someone
who's really shined by that making
friends oh this one touched me when I
read that yeah because I feel like I am
too so I'm with you sometimes you got to
do things that make you a little
uncomfortable because those are usually
really good decisions and that's how you
get out of a place that you're in so I
would say just like even if it's a
little bit uncomfortable go up to people
talk to them or maybe text somebody that
you don't really know but want to get to
know and just and just be honest it's
probably the other person is kind of shy
to approach you to you know I don't know
I've had the same friends as I was time
yeah and that's a great thing
it's know it is it's just it's a weird
thing to step out and be like hey you
want to hang out or you wanna be friends
like hard it's hard so I totally
understand but sometimes you have to and
I'm trying to do that more well we can
hang out any time you like babe perfect
bye you guys
knocking your way
[Music]